Ultimate trolling
OOH YOU BASTARD
Sword throw, sword throOOOOOW
NOOOO
YOU DID NOT PULL!!!!
Well, alright you kiddies!
We're going on a golden rush!
That does not look good for Santa...
WEEELL Santa seems to be okay so I don't think there's gonna be WAAAAAH
COME OOOON bring on the noise
OOOOH Those were my balls! OOOH WHYYY?
HEEEY alright you kiddy, what do you want for Christmas?
Tell me kiddy, what the hell do you want for Christmas?
If you don't tell me in 3 god damn seconds
I'm gonna throw you into the abyss
OH I don't know! I don't know Santa
I wanna (...?) again
You'll shoot your eye out HEEYYYY
99 perceeeeeeent WOW WOW WOW WOW AAAAAAH NOOOO
Please! Spare Santa Claus! Spare him! Spare Santa Claus!
Or take the Kiddies I AAAAH! Okay so this sucks Oho
Yay back away kiddies! Kiddies stay away from there!
It's dangerous HEY! I told you.
Maybe the old man, ZOOOM, OOOH gonna make it!
SEGWAY MAAAN GONNA DIE!
Bicycle dad! I'll get it through SOOOOON!
OOOH YAAAY! SOMEHOW!
Naah gonna go to the grocery someday... ow that, that hurt! OOOKAY!
Naah still alive... NO arg dead!
Yes my love, we are going throUUUGH HURT!
Honey! What happened? You look different, I like it! AAAAAAH
Just need to mow my lawn! OOOW! WHY?
INDIANA JONES GO ON AN ADVEN...ture ooow
Pogo man? Can you win? pogo man OOOOKAY! Didn't even get close!
Just taking my family on an adventure! AAAAAaaaah
Helicopter man maybe? WEEEE OOOW don't love YEAAAAAH! I did it!
WOW Hello oHOHO HAHAHAHA!
Oh okay! I'm not a very good Luke Skywalker, if you know what I mean
Let's see... I've got to destroy the death star YAY!
That guy died. I hope he wasn't my dad or anything
Where MOHOHO! YEAHAHAHA!
IIIII don't know where we are... AAAAH! Kiddies! I don't know what happened!
Okay, I'm upside down already.
OOOOOOOOOKAY! OOOOOKAY! OKAY!
Bash through with my head! ARG!
That was a lot of machetes... That might have been a little overkill!
Let me out please! I'll do anything! I'll give you my body, my soul, my heart, my loooove!
I'LL GIVE YOU MY LOVE! Is my love not worth it? AAAAARG! I guess not.
Herbederby! Come on! HUH!
Let go! LET GO! LET GO! LET GO! LET GO! LET GO! LET GO! LET GO! let go! let AWohohoooow! JUST LET GO!
Why won't you let gooo? Could I PLEASE let go of the ding dong damn THING!
There we go! AAAAH COME ON! AAAAH! AAAAH! AH! AAAAAH! I made it!
93.74% impossible. WEEEEE WOOOOW
TCHECHOWW! UUUUUUGH! Dodge it!
I didn't go anywhere! These dares, they're kind of a nightmare! OOOOOOW
HELLO! OOOOOH! I was gonna make it!
HELLO! WOOOOW! OOOOOKAY! Niargle fiargle(?)
IIIIIIII'M GONNA WIIIIIN! HAAAAAAAGARG HERP AAAAAARGAAH!
HUH Take that JB! This is how much I have ever burn in hatred for you!
Running murderer? Well, HAHAHAHAHAHA!
OH look out! I'm an old man! Who is ready to stab you in the BUTT!
Don't you run away from me!
He has a mu... He i... He's a mu... He has a mu... He is a murderer!
OOOOH I got my shield! You can't do nothing! AAAAGARG AAAAGARG AAAAAAGAARG!
Okay! Nothing bad so far! OW OH OH THAT HURT!
Okay! Santa wants out! Santa wants out! Santa wants oooooo! Santa's ding dong!
PHEW You almost exploded Santa's ding dong!
YEAAA! Alright, everything seems to be oKAAAAAY! OOOOOW THAT HURT!
I don't know anyone so funny!
EPIC TREE SWING! This is it! This isn't exactly as OOOOOOH
I think I'm suppose to let go.
WEEEEEE! OH MY GOD! OOOW! That's morbid!
WEEEEEE! AAAH OOOOOH! HEHOPTI
UUUUUGH! OOOOOOOOOW! Whyyy?
EEEEEEH OOOOOOOH AAAAAAAAH! I'm still alive! Still alive! Still alive!
Hurts! Hurts a lot! Hurts a lot! Hurts a lot! Hurts a looot!
HEHOPTI! HUH! YEAAAAAAAH! OW! That looks painfull... And... I'm dead....
Still going! Still moving! Am I done? Are you done?
Are you kindly done dying yet?... Sir?... Please I'm gonna have to ask you to move on!
HEEEEY!
On les (?) we bombe les murs(?) ! C'est les baguettes, Eiffel Tower and les french
Kill your boss! Well where is my boss? I seem to already be DEAD! How am I gonna kill my boss?
I'm gonna throw my leg at you you BITCH!
Just wait untill I can get some ground traction! If my leg wasn't here, I would kill the EFF out of you BRO
Leg! Get out of here leg! I'm trying to kill my boss leg!
LEG! GET OUT OF MY WAY LEG! STOP GRABBING ONTO YOUR LEG! STOP GRABBING ONTO YOUR LEG!
GOTTA KILL THE BOSS! STOOOOOOP!
Get out of my face, please, thank you. Get out of my face, please, thank you!
Get out of my face, please, thank you! Get out of my face, please, thank you!
Get out of my face, please, thank you! Get out of my!... My face...
Was that a? Oh okay I get it. Wha... Nooo! NOOOO!
Oh! Come on! Kill JB! Just for once! Just do it for me!
DO IT FOR ME BABY! DO IT FOR ME! Do it for you!
Okay, alright! NONONONO! NO! NONONONO! NO! Don't do this! BACKWARDS!
WRONG! WRONG I'm still alive! I can't control it anymore...
Her her mer mer stop! Santa's too fat! Can't fit through gap!
HEY ALRIGHT! YOUAARG! OW! OH NO! SANTA'S NOT (?) AAAAH! OOOH! OH! AAAAAH!
Come here you BITCH! Santa's gonna BLERB Okay! Alright! Okay! Alright! WOW! OW! OH! BER! BERP!
Santa's a bit too fat! A fat little cat! Berp! Berp! BEEEERP!
SHEWORD THROW! SHORTY! SHORTY! GOD DAMN IT
AT LEAST YOU AND ME WENT DOWN TOGETHER JB
WOOPAAAW! Ow! I caught it with my face! Therefore I'm the winner!
Now! Victory! Shall! Be mine!
Come on! Come ooon| Just a little bit higher!
NOOOOO! GET IT! GET IT! HEY! COME ON YOU HAD IT! COME OOOOON! COME OOOON! AAAAAAH!
AAAAAAAH! AAAAAAAAH YOU'RE RIGHT THERE! GET IT! GET IT! GET IT TOUCH IT!
GET IT TOUCH IT! TOUCH IT! GET IT! YEAAAAAAAH!
HOPTAYETOPTAYETOR! At least I did ballet!
Now you get out of here with the trying to kill me bullshit! NAAAAH! AAAAH!
WOW! HI JB!
I'm gonna get you! BER! That's right!
(Mark is singing?)
NOOOO! I WOOOON! What did I win?
WEEEEEEEE! Easy peas... Okay I'm dead!
ALRIGHT! Come on! Come on! Come on baby! Come on baBLAH
WEEEEEEE! Tchicachicachicachica... Ah damn it!
WHAT?!? HOW WAS THAT NOT A WIN?
NEON! SPIKE FALL! Alright you kiddies! Let's (?) this (?) for me! Kiddies? WAAAH! UUUUUUGH!
No need to die this time! I'd rather die in cover (?) for the rest of our lives
Or the rest of MY life apparently because they are dead! BERP! BER! OOOOOH I won that one okay!
POON RUN! WEEEEEEEE! I can't weigth out! (?) Am I dead? I'm dead... Thank you! Thank you! Thank you!
ALRIGHT! Get out of here! Oookay! Get out of here you smarmy bitchies you! GET OUT OF HERE!
That was my sonic (?) ! Okay... Alright! Still... Still go... Still... Still going! Still going apparently! OOOOOOOH If I just keep trying I'm gonna make it eventually!